hello everybody markiplier here and we
just hit 45,000 subscribers last night
and hey I once again I'm taken aback by
how many people that is but I don't want
to just go on a ramble of talking about
you know I'm amazed at how many people
are here I'm amazed at how many people
subscribe to me and think that my
content is good enough because I've said
that already
you know you all know how grateful I am
that you have and I'm grateful to
yamimash for giving me the chance to
collab with him he's given me a lot of
new subscribers and hopefully I've given
him some because he deserves it he's a
great guy I recently did a collab with
miss Monica hopefully you guys saw that
and I was very I'm very happy to do that
with her and other people that I got
collapsing work with them so grateful
that they gave me the chance because I'm
honored to work with these people and um
some of these youtubers that I've
watched before I even started and I
never imagined that I'd be compared to
some of them let alone you know have
more subscribers than others and there
are some youtubers out there that I
looked up to a long time ago that I now
have more subscribers and it's a weird
feeling it's just humbling in a lot of
ways but you all know already how
grateful I am I wanted to acknowledge
that I get more and more emails from
people that I can't respond to a mom but
more and more emails from people who
same it I've inspired them to start
their own YouTube channels or to start
their own thing and I'm really happy
that that's happening because they you
know it's really hard to do something on
your own it's really hard
and it takes a lot of courage to get up
and say that you want to do that instead
of playing it safe and doing something
else I'm not saying you should all
abandon school and try to go into
YouTube no but creating your own thing
if it's art or writing or whatever what
have you just making your own way that
takes a lot of courage because it's hard
to get started and it's even harder to
get other people to appreciate what you
do and I'm lucky in a lot of ways
because you guys have appreciated what I
do and believe in me therefore it's only
fair that I believe in you because if
you're one of those people that send me
an email you know telling me that you've
inspired you to start something else
I'll keep at it you know it takes a lot
of hard work and dedication when I
started out my youtube channel I was
probably working 12 hours a day you know
just trying to get a handful of
subscribers each day but I was happy to
do it because it was it was something
that I wanted to do so if you've got
something to do you got hold onto him
you've got to keep at it you got to keep
that candle burning because if you let
it go out then you may never have
another chance again
and I'm not saying give up anything else
the hardest-working people in the world
only get success because Peck some
people work two jobs just so that they
could focus on their own independent
project they didn't care about those two
jobs but there were the means to an end
you got to do whatever it takes so thank
you guys so much for believing in me and
I'm glad that I've been you know an
inspiration for others I just play video
games on the internet not too
depreciate what I do but if you guys you
guys out there the real the real
creators and the real artists and the
programmers and the writers and new
creative minds you've got so much
potential you only have to believe in
yourself
because if you don't believe in yourself
no one else is gonna believe in you
either so you've got to keep adding so
anyway thank you guys so much for 45,000
subscribers I promise I'm gonna have
something big for 50,000 because that's
a rather huge milestone it's coming up
very soon so thank you all so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye